[Musique]
quant à vous qui êtes passionné par la
politique et qui avait donc pour
beaucoup d'entre vous des ambitions
légitimes
dites vous que ce n'est qu'en créant en
vous même cette rénovation que vous vous
rendrez digne de diriger les hommes qu'à
rediriger n'ai pas commandés
diriger c'est conduire conduire vers un
but vers un idéal auquel on croit que
l'on a fait partager à d'autres et dont
on entre la direction
il arrive que tous ne touche pas la
terre promise
il arrive même qu'elles ne répondent pas
tout à fait à ce que l'on rêvait mais
l'important c'est d'en avoir fait sentir
le besoin pressentir la vision aux
hommes car c'est ainsi qu'on entretient
ce qui fait le plus défaut à l'humanité
d'aujourd'hui je veux dire d'espoir
[Musique]
on